I'm Clint Smith and this is owed to the
only black kid in the class you it seems
are the manifestation of several
lifetimes of toil brown v board in the
flesh most days the classroom feels like
an antechamber you are deemed expert on
all things morrison King Malcolm Rosa
hell weren't you sitting on that bus -
you are everybody's best friend until
you are not hip-hop lyric ologist
presume athlete free and reduced
sideshow exception and caricature to
black and to white all at once if you
are successful it is because of
affirmative action if you fail it is
because you were destined to you are
invisible until they turn on the Friday
Night Lights here you are star before
they render you asteroid before they
watch you turn to dust
for an interview with the poet watch
this video or check out the next poem in
this series